next question is what is the mark of the beast
all right the mark of the beast is identified
as sunday observance but not currently the mark
of the beast will exist after a law is passed
officially making sunday the day of worship on
a universal basis i mean on a global basis when
that occurs and people have to make choices now
between a clear man-made law and god's law those
who choose against god will then have the mark
of the beast so no one has it now but the mark of
the beast is that action which more than any other
establishes the power of the roman church and this
statement is found in their writings they have the
power to change what god has written they have the
power to enact laws and to change laws and so the
mark of the beast and god has a mark ii which is
the seventh-day sabbath or a sign or a token
each power has a mark which is the way it always
is the mark of the beast is the acceptance of
man-made laws above the law of god that's the
mark of the beast and since that law has not
yet been passed no one yet has that mark but
faithful members even now have the seal which is
faithfulness to god expressed through obedience
to his commandments including the fourth because
the fourth commandment is a sign between god and
his people so no one has the mark of the
beast now but many have the scene of god
so the mark again the mark of the observance
but no one has it yet it will only be placed
on people by their choice when they willingly
choose a manmade day above god's sabbath on
the basis of a man-made law that's when
people will have the mark of the beast
revelation gives us two powers christ and satan
revelation gives us two cities jerusalem and
babylon revelation gives us uh two two objects of
worship satan god it's a choice one or the other
of course we know sheep and goats wheat and tares
we know that but revelation you either worship
christ the creator or you worship the devil
through human agents see when someone gives
an offering to an idol it's really given to the
devil because the idol is stone stone doesn't know
anything and so the object of worship that does
not conform with god's system is sin let me say
that differently when someone worships contrary to
god's prescription which is his law that worship
is given to satan even though the people may say
is being given to god if you read exodus 32 the
chapter where they worship the golden calf aaron
said in verse 6 tomorrow is a feast to the lord
that's what aaron said that the day was dedicated
to god but they were worshiping the devil that's
why god wanted to kill all of them and moses had
to intercede let me say it again when aaron and
the others made that calf aaron made proclamation
saying tomorrow is the feast of the lord i believe
that exodus 32 6. the fact it was proclaimed as
a day of god did not make it acceptable to god
because law breaking can never please god the
fact that someone says i keep sunday to honor god
does not mean god accepts it it is no different
it must be it must conform with the law of god
and god's law told the israelites do not make
images do not bow them to them god's law tells
us the seventh day is the sabbath not the first
the seventh day and to keep sunday and say it
is for god your intentions may be right but your
action is wrong and god in his mercy sends light
such as this program to open people's eyes to
teach them that good intentions are not enough
we must worship god in accordance with his
law his prescription and that is condensed
in the ten commandments and that is done
through the power of jesus christ of course